President Trump was inside the White
House on Friday when it was put on
lockdown following an attempted security
breach the Secret Service as a woman
intentionally crashed her vehicle into a
security barrier on the southwest side
of the White House near the old
executive office building she was
quickly apprehended Moeller legi is at
the White House this morning Mulla we're
learning that this was not the first
time this woman has tried to breach
security at the White House well that's
right good morning the Secret Service
says it has had previous encounters with
this woman here at the White House
resulting in several arrests she's been
identified as 35 year old jessica ford
of Luverne tennessee and while no shots
were fired in this incident she has been
charged with possessing a gun moments of
confusion outside the White House Friday
after this minivan with the smashed out
rear window barreled into a security
barrier that person kept trying to push
through the barricade
the tires were burning rubber they were
smoking a lot security personnel moved
quickly arresting the driver without
firing any shots the driver has been
identified as Jessica Ford records show
she has been arrested at least three
times for getting too close to the White
House according to police reports Ford
was arrested last April for trying to
jump a security barrier one month later
she was arrested for allegedly trying to
scale a White House fence and in July
she was met by Secret Service agents at
Union Station and told to stay away from
the White House when she was arrested a
few blocks away police say she had a
copy of the stay-away order in her purse
the commotion occurred during a White
House meeting between President Trump
and Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull after Ford was taken into
custody the president tweeted thank you
to the great men and women of the United
States Secret Service for a job well
done no law enforcement officers were
hurt in the incident Ford is facing
several charges as she was ultimately
turned over to the DC metropolitan
Police Department Anthony Lowell ng at
the White House this morning thanks mola